what were the show happy Valentine's Day
yeah I'm just sure everybody happy that
it's Valentine's Day some people aren't
some people get very bitter on
Valentine's Day right you still don't
know if anybody here on a Valentine's
Day date anybody right now
Wow
that's kind of sad yeah
there's nothing it says I love you like
tickets to a free show oh that's nice is
he really came on a date here oh very
cool
all right how's it going so far really
it was cold the studio is too cold how
dare you
it's a little cold yeah it's for the
equipment all right Andy Richter it also
keeps you from falling asleep
yeah I'm not kidding it's really to keep
you from falling asleep yeah if it's
warm you people zone right out yeah well
this is interesting some interesting
statistics for you this Valentine's Day
Americans are expected to spend 1.8
billion dollars on candy yeah now let's
put that in perspective tomorrow
Americans are expected to spend 1.8
billion dollars on candy yeah our nation
of diabetics
I was sure that would do better let's
move on you're all thinking about your
romantic interest tonight and not these
jokes let's try another one
Kanye West surprise hey what's going on
guys good to see ya
great Valentine's Day show for you
speaking of Valentine's Day Kanye West
did you hear this he's surprised Kim
Kardashian on Valentine's Day by having
Kenny G play in their home yeah so that
marriage is over I've ever give any
Valentine's Day traditions every year no
not really
yeah I have a really sweet lawn a really
sweet tradition every year at 7:00 p.m.
I yell oh [ __ ] it's Valentine's Day then
I pay $600 for ten flowers I've done
that women every year cry sister right
that works now I guess I do have a
tradition I always bring ten flowers to
work and then I sell them to you yes
I see what you did there yes that was
very clever thank you yeah where's my
money he'll get your money all right